Congratulations. You've made it to the end of this unit and made it to the end
of the course. And you now have a search engine running as a web application and
a way to separate the crawling part from the server. There's certainly a lot you
can do to improve that but let's recap what we've learned in this unit. You
learned about how to set up a web application using web.py. And that led us to
the more broadly applicable idea of regular expressions. And then we looked at
how to use files. And to deal with files well, we needed to understand
exceptions. And you use try and except and finally to do that, as well as the
with construct. The other thing we've seen a lot in this unit is examples of
using inheritance. This was the main topic of the previous unit. I'd encourage
you to think about all the places we've used inheritance in this unit to make
things work well, especially the inheritance hierarchy for exceptions. I want to
thank you for taking the class and all the effort that you've put in to get to
this point. You've really learned a lot. I don't think Google is scared of you
yet, but you're well on your way to becoming a computer scientist, as well as to
becoming a proficient Pythonista. There's lots of things you can do from here,
and there'll be more discussion about this in the forms. You definitely know
enough to make your own interesting programs and unleash them all on the world.
And I hope many of you will do that. If you do, I hope you will share it with
us, and there's a site for sharing udacisous projects. Some of the examples
there might give you some inspiration about things you might build. There is, of
course, a lot more to learn. And if you learn more, you'll be able to do more
interesting things in better ways. And I learn new things about computing every
day. I hope you'll continue to learn more after this class, and I hope you'll go
on to do exciting and interesting things. Stay Udacious.